i never took my eyes off my mother i
knew that when we were at the table i would not be
allowed to stay for
the duration of dinner and that in order not
to upset my father
mum would not let me kiss her
repeatedly in front of the  mint
as if it had been in my room
also I promised myself in the dining
room while we were starting to have
dinner that I would feel them approaching to
make advances of that kiss that
would be cyclos and furtive all that I
could do alone  to choose with my
glance of the place of the cheek that
some I will kiss to prepare my
thought to be able thanks to this
mental beginning to weigh notches after
all the minute that grant me and mother
to feel that plays against e mail
but the work  like a painter who can
only get two shots session of
poses prepares his palette and has made
advances from memory according to
everything for which he could at a pinch
do without the presence of the model but
here  that they are going that dinner
merge my grandfather the
unconscious ferocity to say the little one looks
tired should go up to bed undine
twisted tonight's grace is my father who
did not keep as scrupulously as
my grandmother is like to  do the times
of the treaties say yes then we go to
bed I wanted to kiss mom at that
moment we heard the dinner bell
but no let's see the astra mayor
you said goodnight enough to each other as it
manifested
as its price said alarming kull  and
I had to leave his viaticum
he makes me climb each step
of the stairs as the popular expression goes
against the current rising
against my body which wanted to return
to my mother because she did not
have him kissing me in  the
licenses to follow me
this stopover and said to stay where I was
always going so sadly
exudes a smell of varnish that she
is somehow absorbed fixed this
particular kind of grief that I
feel you are every  evening and make it
and perhaps even more cruel for my
sensitivity because in this
active form my little intelligence world
could no longer take its share when
we sleep is that a toothache
is not yet perceived by us  that like
a young girl we
strive 100 times in a row drawn from the water or
like a verse of molière we
repeat are stopped it is a great
relief from nick robins to reveal to us
and that our intelligence can
rid the  toothache idea 2 you
heroic disguises or enclosing
it the inverse of this relief i
found like my grief going up to
my room
entrance 1 - in an infinitely
faster way almost instantaneous both
insidious and russian  by the
much more toxic emulation the
moral penetration of the smell of varnish particular
to this stopover
once in my room
it was necessary to block all the exits to
close the ways to dig my own
tomb  by undoing the covers to
put on my mx shirt in the evening but
before going we ask her to come to
the bed of flowers that we had added in
the room because I was too hot in
the summer under the golden curtains of the big
bed  June movement of revolt
I wanted to move on from a ruse to
condemn I thought I said to my mother
begging her to come up for a serious thing
that I could not tell her in my
letter my cold was that François to
his cook in matton  who was in charge
of taking care of me when I was
overwhelmed refused to carry my world I
suspected that for her to make an
errand in the mother of whom there were
people this goal would seem to her as
impossible as for the doorman of  a
theater to deliver a letter to an
outspoken actor rolled up on stage she
possessed with regard to things that
can can't make themselves an
imperious code useful and uncompromising abandonment
on distinctions 1-1 this
idle sesame what he what  gave him
the app  ence of these anti laws which, alongside
the prescriptions towards us like macra
to massacre children with manna,
forbid with an exaggerated dedication
to boil the cauldron in mourning
for one's mother or to eat in food
the strong link of the crisis  this code,
which we judge by the sudden stubbornness
she showed in not wanting to do
certain errands that we gave her,
seemed to have foreseen
social complexities and slipped up
mundane table nothing in
Françoise's entourage and in her domestic life  of the
village had not been able to suggest them
suggested to him and were forced to say to themselves
that there was an air of a past France is
very old noble and misunderstood as
in these cities manufer su manufacturing
where old bones testify that he had  already
said a life of a couple of course and where the
workers of a chemical factory
work in the middle of the
delicate structure which represents the
miracle of health at the fines or the four
sons aymon in the kop apart
icual article of the code because of which it
was more likely that except the case
of fire françoise à la des reds et
maroons in the presence of better care
for such a small character as me
simply expressed the respect she
professed not only for  relatives
for the dead priests and kings
but also for the foreigner to whom we
give hospitality respect which would
perhaps have touched me in a book but which
deserved all kinds in the mouth
because of your serious and tender  that she
took for a bet is more
tonight than sanctity what a grand
fair and at dinner had the effect that
she would refuse in trouble and
ceremony but to put a chance on
my side I do not hesitate to lie and to
him  say that it was not at all -
who had wanted to write to mum but that
it was mum who in Occitan had
recommended me not to forget to
send her an answer relating to an
object that she had taken from me  seek
and she will be  t certainly very angry
on an option did not give him back to this
world I think that Françoise does not cut me
because as the golden unproductive are
were more powerful
than ours to discern immediately
at decines elusive for better any
truth that we wanted to hide from him
afterwards  guerdat for five minutes
languedoc as if the examination of paper
aspects of
writing east to inform her about the nature of the
content there will learn that she article
of her code
she had to refer then she took out
the nièvre seigner which seemed
tell me if you speak unhappy to decorate parents to see such a child she came back after a while to tell me that we
were still only at the ice cream that it was
impossible for me to deliver the letter
at this moment in front of everyone  world but
that when we're at prince bush between
your wrinkles the way to pass it on to
mum immediately whole world upside down
now it's not like earlier
for up to  hand I'm going to
leave my mother since my little word
go the afa song of duplication
because this ride makes me look ridiculous
in the eyes of care to do it at least
between them is invisible and is delighted
in the same room that she was going to
talk to him  less in the ear since
this hostile forbidden dining room where
there was still ice cream
anna for a moment believing it themes and the
mouthwashes seem to me to harbor
harmful pleasures is mortally
it's because mom we drain is
far from me
to follow and to me and like a fruit gone
mad which breaks its envelope
it closes besides projected until
my intoxicated body mum's attention
while she read the mailing now
I was no longer separated from her the
barriers were  fallen infi delicious
we will have to get together it's a rain
it was not all mum was probably going to
come the anxiety that I had
just experienced I thought that either we
would have laughed at it that's the chosen ones  bad
feeling and we have  guessed the end or on the
contrary as I learned later
a similar point was around the
world for many years of his life and
no one as well as he can be
would have to understand me nice is
black what  there is a feeling of being all the
same in a place of pleasure where one is
not or cannot join
it it is love that made her
know the love to which she is
somehow destined  by
which she will be fit after specialized
but when for me she entered into
we have that she still
appeared in our life she
floats meanwhile will go free sense at
each determined station can serve a
training day the day after
our sometimes 33 billion
or friendship for an executive
and there I see with which I am doing my
first apprenticeship when Françoise they
will tell me that my letter would be delivered
or we had also committed this
young deceiver given to us by some
friends  a few steps  rents of the woman
we love when arriving at the hotel at the
theater where she is for a few
shares are worth dreading a premiere where
he will find her
this friend sees us air andorra
desperately waiting for a few
opportunities to communicate
with her he does not recognize  we
approached familiarly ask us
what we are doing there and
as we have something urgent to
say to undermine returned to him he assures us
that nothing is simpler gets
us into the vehicle where bare
promises  to send it to us before five
minutes that we hand as at this
moment I love and Françoise
the well-meaning intermediary who for
years has just made us bearable
human is almost conducive to
inconceivable fact infernal within
which we believe that
whirlwinds  To make me towards the
divisions between them is far from it
making us laugh at what we have
if we judging by today's parents
who accosted us  and who is also
one of the initiates and imprisoned mystery the
other guests of the party must
have nothing many mosaics his
hours accessible and beg siantou
halal halal and taste the unknown pleasures
here is that by a breach a pre music spirit will be
born here canet  time
whose succession the ears compose
a moment as real as the others
even can be more important for us
because our mistress who is no longer
but the nannies the time we do not
represent we own it
we intervene in it we created it arm the
moment when we are going to tell him that we are
down there and no doubt the other
moments of the party should not be or
of a birth very different from this
one should not be more delicious and
which must make us suffer since
the night  benevolent told us but
she will be delighted to go down that it
will be much more fun to weigh
with the tip of her nose up there
alas either we had experienced it  nce
the good denture attentions are
powerless on a fan who is irritated to
feel pursued even in a party
by someone she does not like often
the target of the senses alone